hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast addressing NGS dead nuns
for third-generation TAC bio sequencing
presented by dr. Jonas Corbin chief
scientific officer at Pacific
Biosciences
I'm Cindy Valdez of Lavery's I'll be
your moderator for today's event we're
excited to bring you this educational
virtual conference presented by
labyrinth the leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
there's what this presentation will run
today you want to hear from you to
questions comments in the answers can be
submitted via the green Q&A button at
the lower left of your screen we'll try
to get everyone but if not we will make
sure to follow up with you by email you
can also enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon at the lower
right-hand corner of the slide window if
you cannot hear this presentation or see
it let us know by clicking on the
support button at the top right or the
Q&A button at the lower left this is an
educational webinar and best offers free
continuing education credits after the
webinar is over please click on the CC
button located at the bottom left hand
corner of your webpage and follow the
process for obtaining your credit let's
now introduce today's speaker welcome
sir dr. Jonas or luck
now thank you very much Susie and hello
everyone I'm Jana scoreless and I would
like to tell you today how
third-generation PacBio sequencing can
address some of the more difficult
regions in the genome for DNA sequencing
I borrowed the term NGS deadzone from an
original research article that was
published by Brigade bunker and others
in genetics and medicine entitled
navigating highly homologous genes in a
molecular diagnostic setting a resource
for clinical next-generation sequencing
and in this paper they point out that
while next-generation sequencing has
been tremendously successful there are
of genes and region in the genome that
are much more difficult to get at the
gen code project identified over 11,000
unique pseudogenes are to date and the
discrimination between pseudogenes and
the gene of interest can in many cases
be challenging for short read
next-generation sequencing and also for
Sanger sequencing and so what that
brings about is a risk of false positive
and false negative variant calls because
there could be an accurate mapping of
the short reads to the highly homologous
regions including pseudo teams basically
because the reads are short you don't
know where they came from or whether
they came from the gene and the pseudo
gene and so in this paper then there are
a number of tables for example this one
where quite a number of clinically
important genes that have been
recognized to cause genetic diseases are
tabulated that are grouped into what
they termed ng as dead zone meaning that
they are difficult or impossible to get
at and fully resolved with either NGS
and there's another table also the
Sanger sequencing and so what I'd like
to tell you about today is how a
different sequencing technology long
respect pyrosequencing can overcome some
of these challenges and fulfill
opportunities that go beyond the
the paradigm of having you know 200 or
300 days there a piece of DNA that you
would like to sequence in many cases on
you would like to do on something that
goes beyond that so I will talk about
full-length phase gene sequencing where
the entire gene is being represented and
sequence and phased into the two alleles
on the mother and from the father allele
to identify and face the heterozygous
snips as well as maybe larger structure
variations an example which is shown
here then already talked about
discriminating a gene from a very
similar pseudo gene and confidently
assigning the mutations coming from
either the gene or the pseudo gene
extreme sequence context very gc-rich or
eighty rich or low complexity sequences
like repeat expansions and I won't have
time to talk today about minor variant
detection and methylation detection and
so I'd like to give some examples of
what a peptide sequencing has been used
to get a much better insight into gene
sequencing in these first three examples
now very briefly about PacBio sequencing
the way this is achieved is through the
different performance characteristics of
single molecule real time sequencing
that Penkala provides you may know that
we're very long leads coupled with a
very high consensus accuracy uniform
unbiased coverage regardless of what the
GC percentage or the sequence is you get
high quality data and then the ability
to determine DNA modification so the
combination of these and for this for
the purposes of this talk of the
combination of the first three enable
addressing these dead zones that are
currently exist in NGS or saying the
sequencing I do want to spend just a
moment talking about the consensus
accuracy and smart sequencing this has
been described and demonstrated in many
papers and so here's just one example of
the first paper a quotation these
authors use smart sequencing to identify
our DNA mutations in HIV treatment in
fact
individuals and they chose mark
sequencing because for them and exceeded
the accuracy achieved by other
sequencing methods and I was able to
provide for them greater than 99.999%
accuracy so how is that done um you may
know that on the individual read level
the error is higher in smart sequencing
however the errors are random so as you
build consensus by building up coverage
so multiple molecules are being sequence
mapped to a reference genome or you de
novo assembly overlaps de novo and then
from the consensus you can then
determine whether they were homozygous
or heterozygous snips so this would be
the mode of using it for genotyping and
Mendelian diseases and because the
errors are random they wash out very
very rapidly so the consensus sequence
is highly accurate greater than 99.999%
or pv 50 i do want to mention that in
smart sequencing there's a special mode
of sequencing that we call circular
consensus sequencing and in this
particular mode the DNA polymerase goes
around the circular smartville around
the hairpin adapter sequencing the
reverse strand of that same molecule and
then when the polymerase gets to the
primer it will displace the primer and
the DNA has just synthesized and we'll
go into this rolling circle mechanism
rolling circle synthesis mechanism
whereby you now get multiple sub reads
that come from the same molecule so with
this technology is possible to sequence
the same base of the same DNA molecule
multiple times forward and reverse and
that you need to smart sequencing no
other technology can provide such high
resolution on and accuracy on individual
molecules and so then you get a very
highly accurate consensus sequence from
that particular molecule by averaging
the sub leaves and so this would be used
in minor variant detection where for
example in the viral space on cancer you
have mutations that only exist let's say
at a 1% frequency in a background of 19
1% wild-type and so forth in either case
this is how the consensus accuracy
develops with a respect to depth of
sequencing and so you can see that at
about 20 to 30 fold coverage Peck file
reaches QB 40 or 99.99% and then around
50 or 60 full coverage it crosses to be
50 99.999% or less than one error in
100,000 bases so this is a way to get
extremely accurate sequence both in a
multi molecule way that's commonly done
from and alien diseases as well as on a
single molecule level and tightly
coupled with accuracy is the question of
whether all sequence context can be
sequence to that same level and that is
not the case with Sanger sequencing or
short rate sequencing for example and in
a reason in an article last year two
years ago there was a comparison a
review article showing that the Illumina
technology has coverage bias relative to
GC rich or 80 rich regions and that's
not present in fact our sequencing where
a one gets uniform coverage and sequence
quality regardless of the DNA sequence
context so then I would like to as I
mentioned in the beginning would like to
give you some examples where these
characteristics have been leveraged for
getting better and more comprehensive
gene sequencing targeted sequencing
addressing some of those NGS dead zones
the first example is an HLA typing and I
won't say much about this because it's
been published on and there's no well
established this is a very nice review
paper if you're interested to learn more
about this HLA typing for the next
generation by Steve Marsh at Anthony
Nolan mr. Ginetta --kx is has typed over
150,000 samples last year alone and so
this is a well-established a method in
the new gold standard in HLA typing
where you now can interrogate and fully
phase the entire HLA both class 1 and
class 2 teams I'm going to speak a
little bit more detail about one example
in the area of drug metabolism and
our merkel genetics that is a gene that
is called 626 a cytochrome p450 that's
very prominently involved in
metabolizing medicines and drugs
this 626 is estimated to metabolize
about a quarter of all currently used
and available drugs in the Western world
and of course it matters with regard to
your 626 genotype on whether the patient
will be a very rapid metabolizers of
that particular drug or maybe a poor
metabolizer and so of course that's of
critical importance to the dosage and
the requirements for particular patients
which can vary by media as much as an
order of magnitude and so if you are if
a doctor would prescribe a dose to a
patient that has a poor metabolizer
that's too high there's a risk of an
overdose for a rapid metabolizers if the
dose is too low then the drug may be
ineffective and the 5th 2016 is very
polymorphic similar to HLA so it's been
difficult to fully characterize and in a
series of two papers on first by
researchers at Mount Sinai describing
the long read single molecule real-time
full gene sequencing of cytochrome p450
2d6 and then more recently by a group in
Europe also describing flexible and
scalable full-length 66 amplicon
sequencing they described how this
particular NGS deadzone can now be fully
and comprehensively interrogated there
was a nice article by stuart scott in
drug discovery magazine describing what
it was more broadly so in this first
paper stuart scott and colleagues first
looked at ten samples that they had
previously characterized with the more
indirect assays like the Luminex assay
or the tacna and copy number essay and
then compared to smart the smart
sequencing essay in several cases it was
possible with smart sequencing to refine
the genotype and there was a
characterization of duplication allele
and then even in those control samples
he found novel alleles that were missed
the other assays and then he went on to
14 samples that had discrepant results
between the other genotyping platforms
and similarly he was able with smart
sequencing to resolve the sub alleles
refine the genotypes find allele
duplications and in one case find a
completely novel tandem rearrangement
that had never been seen before in the
second paper from the European group
they described similar results
sequencing the full six point six KD
fragment covering the entire gene
including the up and downstream regions
and in addition they described a tooth
step bar coding scheme which is very
efficient to move from one locus to
another so two primers are used that
have a universal m14 based tail on both
ends they are used to amplify the
particular region of interest and then
in a second step PCR barcodes are added
that allow them to multiplex and cool
many different samples together which
makes it cost-efficient and this
two-step protocol allows you to move
very efficiently to another locus
because all you need if you want to now
look at a different gene is just two
primers specific primers with the same
tails they would amplify locus two and
then the second step PCR stays the same
and allows for pooling without the need
for significant additional investments
if you want to move to another target in
general I want to just mention that
there is a difference in the overall
design with Peck bio that's afforded by
having long reads as you probably well
know a short read or singer on
sequencing as the gene of interest gets
maybe beyond 500 or a thousand bases you
need multiple primers and multiple
reactions to walk yourself through this
region that's not the case in fact on
sequencing because up to a lot of 10 KB
and I'll even show some examples that
I'll go beyond that it's possible to
just interrogate the entire region with
just one primer pair one long-range PCR
that that's fully sequence them and then
similar to other technologies we have
and eighty-four barcodes that have been
optimized for smart sequencing that
allow the multiplexing and pooling of
hundreds of targets and samples and the
software will automatically be multiplex
there are molecules that are being
sequence and then analyze them
separately in each bin for the barcode
appropriately so then what about going
beyond what can be looked at the PCR we
and our users have tested probe based
capture techniques IBT and nimble Jim
that depending on the particular design
may be preferable and what you can see
the difference here now is though
compared to Shortridge sequencing is
that 5 KB or so fragments in length are
being pulled down in sequence in a
continuous fashion compared to the 200
or so base pair fragments that you get
with your example the Illumina platform
and so this is a standard nimble Jim
Oncology panel so these are genes that
are play a critical role in cancer and
this is a gene mu th why that's involved
in DNA repair a very important cancer
gene and you can see the difference that
here down here in this igv view that's
the gene with the exons in blue
rectangles and then the peg bio-data is
up on top and the corresponding aluminum
data is on the bottom so the probes are
only targeting the exons and so that's
why you only have coverage in these
particular regions where the gene is
fully covered with PEG dial and you can
see snips homozygous and then
heterozygous here they're larger
insertions or deletions in this
particular case in insertion that can be
argued and because the reads are long it
then allows you to face on the reads
into the two haplotypes I show this by
example here for another gene region
this is exon 10 of bracket 1 and we can
then now order these reads very easily
by phasing on the snips the heterozygous
snips and so very easily identify
earlier one reads and allele 2 reads and
building consensus
that's not possible with the short read
my seek data and of course phasing these
heterozygous mutations is critical in
some cases for example in cancer and
tumor suppressor genes you have this
classical two-hit hypothesis that both
copies of the tumor suppressor gene has
to have mutations so that their function
is knocked out and so it's a critical
interest to a clinician to know whether
the observation of two mutations come
from the two different alleles in this
particular case both alleles both copies
of the tumor suppressor gene would be
defective versus having those two
mutations both occurring on one copy on
one allele which means that the other
allele is still intact
which is implications for the tumor
progression and the diagnosis and in
addition it is possible to resolve
larger structure variations so it gives
another example of a cancer related team
and the technology are very clearly show
here in one of the alleles there's a 740
base pair deletion in the other it is
not in the other ends present and that
was not picked up with the Illumina data
this this particular deletion comprises
and contains an entire exon of that
particular gene but that was not
detected with the chaudhary technologies
now then coming back maybe to the title
inspiration of my seminar today
discriminating genes and pseudogenes SIB
2d6 was actually already an example of
this because 626 has a neighboring
pseudo gene that has 97% homology and
because now the reads are longer there's
more flexibility in where you can place
your primers and being unique to the
gene so that pseudo gene contamination
is less of a problem so in this study no
high identities off target sequence
alignments were observed because all the
amplification products came from the
gene with unique primers compared to the
pseudo gene and so a second example
going back to the
ngn bet zone James is PMS too which is
responsible for from colon cancer PMS to
has a very large region of over 99%
similarity to its corresponding pseudo
gene and in a collaboration we
determined the sequence of full sequence
of a 17 KB amplicon that extends over
this region there was no mapping to the
super gene because again all the
amplicon molecules came from the team
and then our automated long amplicon
analysis or la a tool on that part of
smart analysis can be used to then fully
phase into the two alleles this is a
screen shot for two samples the
wild-type sample and then a mutant
sample and you can see over the entire
region of 17 kilobases this is fully
effaced and fully resolved there was a
recent paper that i think highlights
another general opportunity to improve
and optimize the sequencing of genes
that currently is very cumbersome and
only incomplete this comes from Yaya
Anwar and colleagues in Europe and was
test published in human mutation and
they were looking at a team called PK t1
which is implicated in this kidney
disease and the clinical standard right
now is to do a number of long-range PCR
reactions followed by about 40 or 50
nested PCR reactions that specifically
target the exons of that gene and to get
at the this is to get at the single
nucleotide variation and then that is
then combined with a multiplex ligation
dependent probe amplification or MLP a
so that's a another additional assay
that is run for looking at larger
structure variation in the paper he
shows that single molecule real-time
sequencing can get at this particular
gene and a much more efficient and
optimized fashion five long-range PCR
reactions were run and then these
products are sequence in their entirety
they sell about four or five to
fragments that are sequence in one piece
encompassing all the exons and introns
standing regions and lead to a much more
efficient workflow because also the ML
pas is not needed you get both the
single nucleotide variation as well as
the larger structural variation from the
sequencing with Peck file and so they
found excellent importance over 95
percent concordance with the Sanger
results and there were several variants
there were detected with Peck bio that
for mystical singer technology so there
are many examples of genes that are
currently as a standard test being
subjected to this combination of Sanger
sequencing and ml PA assays that as I
said are cumbersome involve multiple
assays are laborious and fairly
expensive that have a good potential to
be replaced by a much more efficient pic
biasing and I want to close the section
by just making a general point that on
the websites these types of assays
currently are advertised as so-called
full gene analysis but you will
appreciate from what I talked before
that often it is not actually looking at
the full gene so it's really most often
a full exon analysis and maybe with the
Junction's between the exons and the
introns but that's different effect by
all the fact by there's a potential to
interrogate the entire gene all the
exons all the introns and detect all the
variants and booting intronic variants
that in some cases may not be clinically
actionable or relevant but splice
variants can certainly be detected this
way it also provides a better
discrimination of pseudogenes because
number one with the long reads there are
more variants in a given sequence read
which allows you to better identify
whether that reach came from a gene or
this corresponding pseudo team and the
intronic variation also can help you
discriminate that so I just want to give
one example highlighting this point
again going back to p.m.
- so in the region of the segmental
duplication between PMS - versus the
corresponding pseudogene PMS - CL within
the exons its 99.2% identical however
over the span of this entire region its
98.2% identical so there's an entire
percentage point of difference that
helps you if you sequence the entire
region to identify where those roots
were coming from and in particular as
one example that I'm going to mark right
here so this exon down here is 100%
identical between the gene and the
pseudo gene so if you just sequence the
exon you would not be able to tell
whether it came from the gene or a
pseudo gene but you see all the red
marks flanking this particular region so
if you sequence a larger region around
the exon it will be possible to very
confidently place those reads and
identify where they came from I want to
move on to extreme sequence context so
eighty rich regions an example is the
Tom forty gene which has been implicated
in a risk for developing Alzheimer's
disease this is being developed as a
biomarker for the risk of Alzheimer's
and there's a clinical trial with Takeda
Pharmaceuticals in Zinfandel a large
clinical trial of thousands of subjects
looking at this particular region the
tone for T gene has a poly T tract that
shown here of 35 T's in the reference
genome and the expansion or truncation
of this particular poly T stretch can
have an effect on the risk of developing
Alzheimer's so this is a view of how
this particular region looks at Peck
bile and you can see that the reads
fully span this particular region and if
you look very closely you can see that
there's really two groups of reads
present I'm going to reorder the same
data to make this a little more clear so
you can see half of the reads have a
region that is short that only has a
portion of the red bars which are the
t's followed by a deletion and have the
reads have a stretch of
cheese that's very similar in length to
the reference and so then you can use
the consensus color to identify the two
alleles so allele 1 has 15 ts allele 2
has 30 40 s in this particular sample
compared to the reference or 35 T's and
these are the kinds of polymorphisms
that are quite difficult even with
Sanger technology to resolve on the
other end of the spectrum of gc-rich
regions this is an example for fragile X
syndrome in the fmr1 gene
Paul Heyman and colleagues had
demonstrated quite a while back that pic
bio sequencing allows for sequencing
through these very GC rich regions of
DNA more recently a paper has appeared
looking at AGG interruption specifically
and these interruptions of an AGG of one
or two AG G's in this sea of CG G's as a
big impact on the risk from the mother
giving birth to a son that would have
the full fragile X syndrome so 80% risk
with 0 ad G's going down to 15% having
to ADT's in this particular length of
the CGG repeats so it has significant
implications on prenatal testing on
parental counseling and so forth to know
exactly what the repeat expansion is and
what the sequence there in this so in a
paper late last year by yours varnish
and colleagues in Europe it was
described that single molecule or FM
sequencing provides a very robust and
powerful ante to detect these AGG
interruptions in these FMO on pre
mutation carriers they use the circular
consensus sequencing to identify
molecules and then in a de novo fashion
identify and characterize the AGT
interruptions and in some cases
resolving situations which were quite
difficult from which were difficult to
unpossible to get it with other
technology so they certainly envision
what this method
Tate's the research and the diagnostic
analysis for this particular repeat
expansion now more generally there are
many repeat expansion diseases
neurological diseases that have at their
heart the causative variant a expansion
of a low complexity sequence like a
triangle glue tied or tetranucleotide
repeat and some of these can't even be
amplified with PCR and the previous
papers was still possible but some of
these are not readily amplified with PCR
or other amplification techniques and
for this reason we have we are in the
process of developing an amplification
free target enrichment that uses the
caste 9 enzyme and its guide RNA
mechanism for targeting and cutting a
particular region out of the genome and
so then in this workflow where you first
make a normal smart girl library then
target your region of interest with the
Casa 9 enzyme and then subjected to
smart sequencing native DNA would be
sequence so there's no amplification
step involved which then allows you to
get at those tricky regions and also
because of the guide RNAs it's
compatible to look at multiple targets
and of course it's amenable to bar
coding so you can imagine a gene panel
for repeat expansion disease targets and
that we've done in a test run targeting
four of these diseases in one scene in
the same reaction
this is Huntington's disease fragile X
syndrome FML one the ALS locus that's
Lou Gehrig's disease and then SCA ten is
a spinal cerebellar ataxia one of those
texted diseases and in the bottom graph
you see the human genome so on the
left's chromosome one and then all the
way to chromosome y and the y axis is
the number of molecules that were
sequence and so you can see the
annotation all four targets were
enriched for and enough molecules were
gathered in sequence to allow for
determining consensus and so this is
then what the visualization looks like
on the left for Huntington's disease the
you see very clearly the two alleles on
the top there's 18 th es followed by 10
C Gigi's and then on the bottom 60 CAG
is followed by to see des and then on
the right graph fmr1 fragile X syndrome
on the top mountain there 13 CGS with to
AGG interruptions those are the yellow
orange lines and then the second allele
119 CGS with one AGG so very clear and
comprehensive characterization of these
particular disease types
now beyond targeted sequencing I'd like
to close my talk today and talking about
two other NGS dead zones that are
outside of the the realm of targeted
sequencing but also have been quite
difficult and in some cases impossible
to characterize with next-generation
sequencing techniques and here as well
peg by sequencing offers new solutions
and new answers on the first of those
two other examples is in the area of
full-length RNA seek RNA T and which we
call isoform sequencing or ICC for short
and of course it's been well recognized
that there is a tremendous complexity in
gene expression where from a given gene
there would be many different types of
mRNA isoforms that would be formed it's
now estimated in fact that over 95% of
all human genes are alternatively
spliced and the average number of
spliced isoforms per gene is estimated
to be around 8 so there's this
tremendous complexity that's been
recognized to be very difficult to
resolve with the shorter e technologies
because relying on the reads that
spanned of Blois junctions does not
carry enough information to then
reconstruct the picture above of all the
different mRNA isoforms in contrast
we've developed a solution which we call
SOC price upon sequencing that uses the
smarter context cDNA kit to make
full-length cDNA libraries
so each molecule each see DNA molecule
represents a full-length mRNA that same
sequence with long we take our
sequencing and so the reads coming off
the sequencer are automatically
full-length RNAs and so there's no
assembly required non-return oven enough
you also have to have lack of bias this
was a paper two years ago by the AOA BRF
consortium comparing the different
technologies so from left to right the
rows four by four Illumina then over
here you have the crank biotechnology
and then on the right the ion torrent
life tech and what's here on the y-axis
is the five prime end of the mRNA and
the top and then going down to the three
prime end and you can see in the heat
map that the Peck biotechnology provides
a much more even representation over the
full-length mRNAs in many cases in most
in most cases with the other
technologies there's a lack of coverage
on the feed five front end which are
commonly gc-rich
so coming back to the sequencing bias
which causes problems and causes the
dead zones in particular transcripts and
transcript isoforms so I want to give a
couple examples
this one is published the others will be
unpublished this was one of the first
and I guess no one could take classical
papers for eyes to see where when Wong
and Stanford and others looked at the
human embryonic stem cell transcriptomes
one of the best characterized
transcriptomes and found that the there
was a lot of new discovery 273 new genes
and many different isoforms that has not
been seen before and has represented in
NGS deadzone and they had concluded in
the paper that even the process of
identifying all the genes in a human
genome even in these well characterized
human cell lines and tissues was likely
far too complete I wanted to mention
this paper because more recently some of
those discoveries that were made in that
paper some of those new genes were
subjected to a much
closer analysis and so in this paper
some of these non-coding RNAs that were
discovered in the in the PNAS paper were
shown to be critically important to
regulating absolute potency during to
improve floatation development and
during the clear reprogramming so it
takes some time to go from the discovery
to understanding a function but this
paper I think highlighted very nicely
that these new discoveries that are now
filling out the previous NGS deadzones
are not just some less important genes
and other biological features they're
critically important to understand very
crucial biological functions if you want
to read more about this there was a very
nice commentary and feature a technology
feature in nature a little while back
finding function in history transcripts
that sort of tells the story and also in
the area of long non-coding rnas on this
paper is now in the bio archives by the
Genco consortium using smart sequencing
to approximately double the number of
annotated complexity of the target
low-side generating full-length
transcript models that allow to
definitively characterize the genomic
feature of these long non-coding RNAs
that are notoriously more difficult to
characterize and thereby removing a
long-standing bottleneck of
transcriptome annotation previously this
was very cumbersome and required manual
quality curation and finishing and this
can now be done in an automated manner
with high throughput through the use of
smart sequencing so another NGS deadzone
cook video considered the long
non-coding rnas and those are now also
being illuminated by PacBio third
generation sequencing a very new paper
that's now impressed is looking at
androgen receptor variants and so in
prostate cancer androgen deprivation
therapy is currently the standard of
care however
one of the major limitations is the
development of resistance and so there
are these castration resistant prostate
cancers or CR pcs that remain those
second leading cause of male cancer
death and the drug resistance is often
mediated via the expression of androgen
receptor variants so in this new paper
by Scott beam and colleagues they use
the researchers use mark sequencing to
get a better picture of these androgen
receptor variants and their expression
and how that relates to predicting
resistance so the energon receptor gene
structure is shown here and the full
neck antigen receptor has eight exons
but then these variants are often
truncated and can involve these cryptic
exons that are shown here in red and are
denoted this at CC 5 and C 3 and so in
particular a rv7 which has a CD 3
variant truncated cryptic exon and al
benign which has a c5 were were being
looked at on their constitutively active
and often mediate of the drug resistance
and so in fact ARV 7 is being developed
as a predictive biomarkers for primary
resistance to these particular therapies
in CRP C's in this type of prostate
cancer and but it had been known that
multiple additional variants are
expressed and the extent of which their
Co expressed or predict resistance was
not known and so in the study the
researchers used smart sequencing to
look at isoforms of the entire AR gene
structure which is shown in more detail
here there's a large tandem duplication
inside the gene that's about 35 kilo
bases and contains exon 3 and some other
cryptic exons in duplicate copies and so
then applying Pekar sequencing I so see
being a office get a very detailed
picture of the complexity and I won't go
into this in detail only to say that
each row here is a different isoform
that was characterized and identified
with PEC by
you see on the on the right here in this
table that several of them are
completely novel but highlighted here in
in the shaded box you can see that both
ARV nine here and ARV seven are
expressed to a large degree the bar here
refers to the abundance this is just
molecular recount
so they're both every nine of a every
seven are expressed in both alumina and
PacBio shown this expression however
only the step egg bio-data it was
revealed that the three prime terminus
of ARV nine is actually located at the
end of the cryptic exon 3 with no
intervening splicing and that's denoted
by this error right here so everything
in the table you see here is red is a
new splice our new slice junctions both
on the three prime end the five prime
end and refer to new knowledge new
discoveries so what that meant is that
the a rv9 was miss annotated previously
and the terminal x1 is actually much
longer than previously annotated it's
about 2.4 kb and whereas previously this
was this particular isoform was
annotated like this with just having the
c5 now through Packer I to seek is
understood that's actually much longer
and encompasses both te 3 in intervening
sequence and to e5 that is significant
because previous studies have had
directly targeted ce3 that's highlighted
here with the last arrow with the
thought being that it would be specific
to a rv7 but now the realization that a
rv9 also has that particular cryptic
exon 3 would justify or would
necessitate a reassessment of the data
that were used to infer Arva rb7
function so with this more complete
isoform information these data have to
be reassessed because anything that
because both of these are co-expressed a
REM 9 and every 7 both mRNAs can be
knocked down that by the s RNAs that has
been used previously to characterize the
AR v7 function and then it was shown
that transaction of cell lines with the
si RNA is targeting CA 3 reduced the
expression of both AR b7 and AR v 9
whereas if you target c5 that was
specific to every 9 so that is critical
implications for the previous knowledge
about the function and the unknown
expression and constituting of a every 9
requires now clinical evaluation of drug
resistance studies and so forth I think
in the interest of time I'm going to
skip through this particular example and
only to mention that within the context
of Isis see we have an improved protocol
that is now available on the website
that has a streamlined workflow no
longer requires a site selection that
was previously possible on the our
previously necessary on the RS 2 and
this is available on our website and
there are many we see ISIL seek is one
of the most fast-growing areas of use
cases for the venkata technology that
many papers that are now available and
growing fairly rapidly so on our website
and publications page where you can look
at more examples for ISO C so then
lastly in the area of whole genome
sequencing there's another NGS dead zone
as it were because structural variations
have been very difficult to characterize
with next-generation sequencing we know
that structural variation so non snip
variation is widespread and actually
accounts for the majority of the genetic
variation so this is a paper from 2007
so 10 years ago we already recognize
that there's more structural variation
in terms of the number of bases than
snip variation so for Craig Venters
genome it was
that 74% of all variant bases are non
Smith DNA variation so 3/4 of all the
bases that make you different for me are
not in Smith's and so what do I mean by
structured variation I mean the various
types of larger differences between my
genome and let's say the reference
genome deletion 10 of duplications
variable number 10 repeats insertions
and variants and so forth and it's been
well recognized in the community now
that short reads massively parallel
sequencing is insufficient to generate
high-quality genome assemblies and
resolve most structural variation and
this was an editorial on the bottom in
Nature Genetics entitled whole genome
question mark that said that it is no
time to stop thinking that merely more
DNA sequencing meaning short reach
sequencing will give us the variants
that determine human traits and this
period this commentary points out that
long repaid bio sequencing can get
access to that hidden variation that has
been an NGS deadzone until now the first
example that demonstration that smart
sequencing is able to illuminate this
particular dead zone came from the lab
of Evan Eichler in the nature paper
resolving the complexity of the human
genome using smart sequencing there have
been many other papers now either
genome-wide or looking at particular
regions highlighting structure variation
and I won't go into those as much but I
do want to comment on one transition
that we're now seeing which is that this
is starting to be used in the clinical
research context this was a
collaboration with un actually that he
presented at the ASHG meeting looking at
a patient that has a heart problem so
even actually the cardiologist and the
the particular patient has issues with
tumors growing in his heart and people
has been considered for heart transplant
and the clinicians wanted to know what
the underlying genetic defect was in
order to get some
get an estimate of how successful the
heart transplant might be so the axial
mo sequence of short reads and the
genome of sequence but the clinical
testing came back negative and so we
collaborated to look whether long
respect our sequencing could identify
the particular variant just tenfold
coverage was enough to get a good view
of the structure variation map in this
particular patient um so this was on the
run on sequel system identifying about
7,000 deletion 7,000 insertions and
identifying a 2.1 KB deletion that
removes the first coding exon of this
particular PHA or one aging which had
previously been in omen characterized as
causing autosomal dominant Kearney
complex which sits the phenotype quite
well so through Pekar sequencing it was
possible to identify the particular
genetic underlying reasons for this
particular disease and this has been
described in more detail in a paper by
the bio archives and the paper
understand is not formally accepted and
should come out in genetics and medicine
fairly soon now going beyond looking at
structure variations against a reference
genome we have seen demonstrations and
publications on putting together a human
genomes from scratch in de novo assembly
so ultimately the reference has been a
great guiding scaffold and guiding post
for the research community but it is
more difficult to find for example the
ethnic differences and define sequence
that is prevalent in particular
ethnicities that's not apparent in the
reference genome and so a number of
papers have appeared on describing the
high-quality PacBio genome assemblies of
a Chinese genome Korean genome this was
a nature paper last year but so at all
we're presenting the most contiguous
diploid human genome assembly to date
that's the Korean reference genome and
on the right again you see here that
thousands of novel deletions and
novel insertions in particular were
identified as part of sequencing that
just that one individual and
highlighting how much of a dead zone
that has been to the detection using
shortly technologies so what we are
pleased to see is now efforts by the
scientific community to establish high
quality de novo assembly it's using Peck
biotechnology across the different
ethnicities all over the globe and I
think that will be a transformative
addition of knowledge to our
understanding of the complexity of the
human genome within the human population
it's fair to say that these efforts are
still a substantial research effort so
it it wouldn't be really scalable to
what would be certainly be the goal more
long term to subject hundreds of
thousands or maybe tens of thousands of
individuals to a de novo assembly type
paradigm and so with that I want to give
some insight into our plant roadmap on
that we believe will deliver that a
particular type of capability so that's
of course related to throughput as we
increase the throughput on the sequel
system per run correspondingly the cost
gets reduced and so over the next two
years we have the following roadmap in
2017
we will increase the throughput per
smart cell run by a factor of two we
will repeat that improvement in the year
of 2018 another twofold increase on top
of that and then at the end of 2018 we
will introduce a new smart cell for the
sequel system that has an Eightfold
increase in the number of VM double use
compared to the one million that's there
now to an 8 million chip these
performance improvements are
multiplicative so 2 times 2 times 8
that's about a factor of 30 increase in
the throughput of sequence basis per
smart cell run and that corresponds to
about 150 giga bases per smart cell when
that is realized
about 50x coverage of the human genome
and which will be enough to allow for
general assembly like the ones I
described and of course the novo
assemblies in the clinic have been
called for by the community and by
leading scientists this was Jim lutzky
I'm saying that for him de novo
assemblies in the clinic that would be a
goal that he would really really want to
strive for well recently Evan Eichler
says if we're still aligning sequences
simply and that's our only way for
understanding genetic variation to a
reference genome ten years from now
clinically I think we failed what we
really need to think about is how to do
this right and that means understanding
all the variation from stem to stern in
these genomes by that he means the noble
assemblies and of course the difference
between a de novo assembly and a so
called whole genome sequence that was
done with NGS has been also commented
and recognized this is a very famous
graph on the left celebrating the cost
improvement of what it takes to sequence
the human genome but what has been also
been noted is that there is a
discrepancy between the quantity and the
pure cost and the corresponding quality
because a genome that was sequenced and
assembled back here back then here was
of a different very different kind of
quality from what's being done here or
than today in fact the NHGRI in 2008
changed a very definition of what it
means to sequence a human genome to
account for just mapping and aligning
rather than going to a general assembly
and so on researchers like David
Haussler
have commented a few years ago I love
these charts that we've been seeing with
the Moore's law but there's a lot of
wishful thinking in there those arms
genome and so what we've been living of
course through the last few years is the
so-called thousand-dollar genome and as
many recognize that largely focused on
tabulating snips in compared to a
reference genome and with the roadmap
and with the performance improvements
that I've outlined we believe that at
the beginning of
19 we will have the fruit quote at a
point where that same amount of money
will give a PacBio genome however that
will be a real actual genome with the de
novo assembly characterizing all the
single nucleotide variation as well as
the structural variation if you're only
interested in the structure variation
tenfold coverage is enough as I
mentioned in one of the examples and
that would be a few hundred dollars and
so this I think it's been well
recognized for some time that the
quality of the tech biotechnology is
there and it was a through port and a
cost issue and so many have commented
that if you can make long reads both at
a high quality and also cost effective
then perhaps there wouldn't be a need
for the short reads for many of these
projects especially in renewable
assembly and population sequencing space
so we are pleased to see that this
transition is now coming to pass and
that there are institutions especially
in China getting ready for running large
population scale projects using
technology cleansing addressing and the
NGS deadzones that I mentioned and
particularly in population sequencing
with multiple purchase of units and
really scaling up the Peppa Pig bio
sequencing component so with that I
would like to close and summarize that
in all three of these NGS dead zones in
targeted sequencing with the various
different flavors that I talked about in
RNA seek in characterizing the
complexity of transcriptomes
and in the area of detecting and
characterizing structural genetic
variation and ultimately leading to a
leading to a de novo assembly PacBio
sequencing has a lot to offer and can
provide new assays and solutions and
that lead to new discoveries new
clinical research and tests that will
benefit the patients so with that this
is my first acknowledgment slide because
you've seen that most of the things that
I
talked about we're not done by us they
were done by the scientific community
and so I'd like to express my gratitude
to the researchers who invest time and
effort in applying the technology
driving the technology forward
in many cases and we are deeply indebted
to them for their efforts on also and
this is then the the manifestation of
these efforts they're now over 2,000
peer-reviewed publications about three
to four new papers per day on the use of
Python sequencing in the various
different application areas and then
finally I'd like to thank all the staff
at Peck pile who work hard every day to
bring this technology to your research
as well so with that I'll stop and I'd
be happy to take any questions thank you
so much dr. baurel access informative
presentation we're going to begin our
Q&A segment so there's a reminder of how
audience members can communicate with us
questions can be submitted in the Q&A
button at the lower left if we are
unable to get to your questions you time
constraint Center for life will be
answering these questions via email so
let's take a look at our first question
dr. Corwin can you say a bit more about
the practical aspects of carrying out
PacBio sequencing examples like library
breath current spooky performances and
data answers
yes certainly I'd be happy to so with
regard to the library preparation it's
quite similar in terms of the steps that
are needed the molecular biology to what
researchers are used to for Illumina
sequencing
so there's ligation steps and the
cleanup step and then you bind to limb
raise and then goes to sequencing so we
have protocols on our website that for
the different applications whether it's
amplicons or structural variant
detection or Isis seek I mentioned one
of the protocols that's in my talk so we
have many more of these types of
protocols that in a very detailed
fashion outline the steps all the
materials that are needed and the
detailed protocols step by step to go
from the DNA material to the library
that would then go in the sequencer so
that's fully supported for dozens of
different application spaces it's quite
similar to what you would be used to an
illuminating Illumina library we have
automated solutions on the robotic
handling systems if you have lots of
samples that would allow you to make
that more cost-efficient and do that
enhanced automated hands-on and an
automated fashion and so if those
solutions are available on our website
with regard to the sequencing itself um
I did include a slide here showing the
current performance we released the
latest chemistry was released in January
which is the version to chemistry which
typically provides in total terms of
foodcourt about five to eight Giga bases
per smart cell run the average read
length depending on the application can
vary range between 10 and 18 kilo bases
I mentioned the high consensus accuracy
on that is greater than 350 at about 50
or 60 fold coverage and you see on the
picture on the right that there is a
robotic station in the sequel system
which allows the user to run multiple
samples and multiple smart cells in an
automated walk away fashion so up to 16
smart cells can be run
in a single run and the acquisitions are
quite fast so depending on the use case
the movie times the sequencing runs can
be as short as 30 minutes and as long as
10 hours so compared to other
technologies it's quite rapid and that's
because of the real-time nature of the
sequencing and so that that can be quite
fast with regard to data analysis we
have a full software package as part of
the sequel system it's called smart link
that has several modules data management
run QC stats that can be pulled up and
then with regard to data analysis our
smart link analysis package which for
the different application gives you a
user-friendly and user interface
workflows for amplicon analysis and
alien diseases for minor variant
detection or structure variation
detection for de novo assembly and for
Isis ich etc so there's a full software
package that's freely available that is
there for the users we do also of course
have advanced analysis pipelines for
expert bioinformaticians
that can do more than the user interface
and that's available as well
if you doctor for lack it looks like we
have another great question who should
someone contract if they're converted in
purchasing or and we're running the
PacBio solution yes certainly thank you
and so we are a global organization that
has that sells on the systems globally
and we have sales and support on both in
terms of instrument support as well as
application support bioinformatics
support alongside with the sales
representatives all over the world and I
would say in general our website is a
great gateway to get that information
get in contact with us so if you go on
our website there are links that give
you information about the different
there the contact link also about
service providers as that is of interest
we have a quite a number of service
providers all over the world and so I
would say our website is a great gateway
to get more information as well as get
in touch with us if you're interested in
running PacBio projects or purchasing a
sequel system looks like that with all
of the questions for today's event
doctor : do you have any closing remarks
you'd like to share with the audience
thank you Susie and thanks again for the
organizers for giving me the opportunity
I was hoping to give a broad overview
over the different application areas I
have focused on the human biomedical
space and of course there are many
different other areas that I didn't have
time to talk about microbial infectious
disease viral applications plant and
animal sequencing etc so if you're
interested in those get in touch with us
and so there are many different areas
that I couldn't in the interest of time
here
talk about and and also with regards to
the things that I did talk about I'd
like to encourage you to contact us and
we would be happy to discuss your
particular interests in detail scoping
out and and guiding the experimental
design of what Tec bio might be able to
contribute to your research so by all
means I'd like to encourage you to
contact us and if you have your favorite
teams and want to know how to press
apply tech bio then please get in touch
with us and please love to chat with you
about that and then scope I output what
that would look like with Peck biome
thank you very much thank you very much
thank you again dr. Jonas Carla I also
like to take an opportunity to think
elaborate today for making today's
educational webcast possible today's
webcast will be available on-demand
viewing through August 2017 keep an eye
out for email with lab roots alerting
you to this webcast and how will be
available for rebuttal
we encourage you to forward the
announcement you're calling queue
management today's live event thanks for
joining us and hope we see you next time
right